outrage is growing in beirut after last
week's deadly explosion
violent new protests erupted over the
weekend as demonstrators call for the
president
and government to resign at least 158
people were killed in the explosion and
more than 6
thousand injured mts tayab reports from
the lebanese capital
protesters stormed the gilded offices of
major government ministries
pillars of power they say only function
to prop up the corrupt political elite
thousands of the desperate and the
traumatized gathered in the heart of
their shattered city shouting
revolution but almost immediately were
met
with tear gas this isn't just protests
this is a call for a revolution to rise
up against the ruling class
they say destroyed their lives some here
are calling for blood
while others only want their leaders
who've been in power for decades
gone they don't care about the people we
want them all
out nearly half of beirut was devastated
in the massive explosion
caused by over 2 700 tons of ammonium
nitrate
carelessly stored at the downtown port
world leaders are pledging nearly 300
million dollars in emergency
humanitarian aid
including the u.s but there are strings
attached
no money unless economic and political
reforms
are made the question now is will this
criminally corrupt government
who hold on to power with a vice-like
grip let go
for cbs this morning infyostab beirut